ناو ان اوريكما كانتي 6اس ان سيف اندرويدز
كما كان متوقعا ترامب سيسعى للعوده الى
البيت الابيض في 2024
عبر اعلان شبه رسميا خلال تجمع الانتخابي
في ولايه ايوا ولكن الرئيس السابق يركز
على هدف اقرب الان السيطره على الكونجرس
في الانتخابات النصفيه التي تجرى في
الثامن من نوفمبر
[تصفيق]
يبه
لموقع اكسيوس الامريكي كشف عن ان الدائره
المقربه من ترامب تجري مشاورات بشان
اختيار الرابع عشر من نوفمبر كم موعد
لاعلان اطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه التقرير
لفت ايضا الى ان ترامب لم يحسم قراره بشان
التوقيت وان الموعد غير مؤكد
ترامب اصبح اقوى رجل في الحزب الجمهوريه
ويدعمه الكثير من مرشح الحزب في سعيه
لاستعاده السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ والنواب
كما يحدث ترامب بتاييد كبار رجال الحزب
مثل كيفما كارثي زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس
النواب ويرى الاخير ان فوز حزبه مؤكد في
الثامن من نوفمبر
سيسعى لاستغلال زخم فوز الجمهوريين في
الكونجرس لاطلاق حملته الجديده